on Friday American b1b bomber Jets
carried out 85 air strikes in Iraq and
Syria on members of the Islamic
revolutionary guards Corps kuds force
and the fighters they support the
payback for these groups drone strike on
a US base in northeastern Jordan which
killed three US soldiers and injured
dozens of others the Biden
administration had promised retaliation
we've not described what our what our
response is going to be uh but we look
to hold the people that are responsible
for this accountable and we also look to
make sure that uh we continue to take
away capability from them as we go
forward on Friday evening President Joe
Biden issued this comment on the start
of the air strikes our response began
today it will continue at times and
places of our choosing while the US says
air strikes will continue against
iran-backed proxies officials are
concerned there could be consequences
they can't anticipate especially if they
continue to rely only un overwhelming
Force rosn Jordan aljazera the
Pentagon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer